you spoke and your voices were heard
seems that you can't get enough of top
fight videos well me neither so now
let's go over some more fights
I consider noteworthy 20 19's behind us
but there's no problem with taking a
look back at ten more key anime fights
that happen last year now is there yep a
rev up and get ready for volume two of
the top ten fights in 2019
[Music]
we open with a fight in war-torn Europe
this is the Ugur senki movies keep at
all Tanja vs. Mary in many ways you
argue that Tanja and Mary are foils and
alternative versions of each other in
fact Mary's promotion was on the sole
basis of her combat prowess and her
ability to match Tanya as such it's
fitting that the two perfect matches go
head-to-head in combat and that's
exactly what the yujo sinky movie
delivered the back-and-forth battle in
the movies a sight to remember after
Mary delivers a beat-down and seemingly
finishes Tanya the latter isn't quite
dead and turns the tides on her nemesis
Mary may have the advantage of physical
power and stats but it's the one with
the better tactics that wins out in the
end of this pivotal confrontation
rival team ups are exciting especially
those of a rivalry with the same scale
as Darcy and two years one of the key
fights in the third season of Bongo
stray dogs forces the two combustible
elements to team up against them is
Rondo and his hyperspace ability one
which proves to be a tough nut to crack
as it transcends the realm of ordinary
abilities and material laws regardless
fans were excited to see one of the
series most popular antagonists team up
with a key protagonist and a longtime
nemesis their combination works really
well too why is it in anime that the
hero's best partners his arch nemesis or
biggest rival the tenth battle ends in
style with the two sworn rivals holding
hands and delivering a finishing move
the wins the drawn-out fight for the
tandem
yeah
[Music]
sunbath sudo
ensemble flights are fun especially if
they feature many heroes working
together to take down a seemingly
unbeatable foe they're even more fun if
the opening theme suddenly blasts midway
through the fight even the good guys
that power up and with that I just
described the heroes battle against the
Pope bulma's in rising of the shield
hero the four heroes and their
companions find their way deep into the
church of the three heroes and their
showdown against the master of magic
Pope's one hell of a payer for all of
that build up the sweet part of these
fights is the characterization being
shown our four heroes make a combustible
element together and when they are
fighting together I'd say that the way
they fights not bad at all it's also
nice to see now fool me calling the
shots and leading the team to victory
after all that's happened in the past
episodes
yukimaru and tahoe Morrow's epic battle
serves as the climax to doora rope with
only his eye and arms remaining
yukimaru's quest to become whole is at
its end and who better to be his final
opponent than his brother the two
already clashed but it didn't have that
big fight feel like this one did they
finally had their decisive jewel inside
the burning castle and he akamaru wins
but spares his brother the eye diamond
takes matters in his own hands but with
Tahu Maru sacrificed Shikamaru defeats
the demon and finally becomes whole
again that's a nice way to end the whole
thing alright also don't tell me that
you didn't feel sorry for Tahu Maru at
the end he deserves a happy ending as
much as everyone else with that being
said this battle won't be the last
sibling fight on this list
[Music]
[Music]
heck you turkeys
okay then it sues magnum opus in the
first season of demon slayer has to be
this fight among his two moments of
awesome in the series this is often the
more talked about one and for good
reason to surrounded by a horde of tiny
spiders cygnets who powers them off by
going super saiyan charging up and
making a beeline for the demon the
yellow demon slayer dances through the
moonlight as he makes a spectacle out of
crushing the spider demon it's worth
noting there's in its who finished off
his demon by himself whereas both tan 0
and eNOS K had trouble with theirs while
this may be the result of being assigned
a weaker opponent I'd like to think that
this fight looks - builds in its ooh up
to be that one big badass that you
wouldn't want to underestimate just
because of his temperament this is
barely a fight for the poor old spider
demon
that's what you get for under estimating
this Slayer
[Music]
for the third-ranked entry we have a
textbook example of how to build up a
villains credentials after defeating
elves possessing Klaus and Harmon asked
her and you know find themselves
fighting licked in one swift motion lick
not only closed the distance on the two
of them but also sent us the flying in
one fell swoop you know lasted a bit
longer but even he couldn't find a way
to overcome the elf who keeps reflecting
attacks the fight was short-lived at
both aster and you know find themselves
on the receiving end of a glorified
squash match the boys are just
outmatched licks an opponent way beyond
their league and it really does show in
this fight when they do get a rematch
let's hope our protagonists come more
prepared I think that they've got a long
way to go
[Music]
things are kicked into high gear by fire
forces 21st episode the anticipated
battle between Shinhwa and show finally
happened and it was amazing the build
ups they're the siblings quickly get on
with a furious exchange ever wondered
what a battle between two uses of a
dollar verse would be like look no
further
kudos to David production for being at
the top of their game in animating this
exciting fight they nailed it and I'd
say this fight is right up there when we
talk about peak fire force everyone so
caught up with demon slayers 19th
episode but I think this fight deserves
a lot of praise in its own right rarely
do you see such movie tier animation
done in a seasonal anime unless you are
you for table that's largely why this is
a fight that surpasses what we saw in
the source material and is truly
something to remember 2019 for
especially for fire force fans
another one fight in volume 2 of the top
10 2019 fights is a shimazaki versus
everyone hmm why does this one look so
familiar yep you're not seeing things
one of the best one-man army fights in
anime makes its return as the top entry
of another list it's never a bad time to
once again lay witness to shimazaki z'
moment in mob Psycho season 2 the
arrogant shimazaki provokes the former
scars into fighting him while numbers
would say that the odds are against him
no numerical odds are too big for a key
villain to overcome when his